[Music]
on this tuesday night more vaccine doses
and more
coveted cases promises thousands more
canadians will be vaccinated by the end
of the year
no one and no community will be left
behind as more canadians roll up their
sleeves
the agony of what's happening in
alberta's icus
we're the only ones there to hold their
hand and uh
that is killing us plus quebec goes from
strict to an even stricter lockdown
a canadian fashion mogul in custody the
accusations of sex crimes against peter
nygard
and more name dropping we're never
trying to be disrespectful
the name of cleveland's baseball team
has finally struck out
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
[Music]
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin with news about vaccines more
canadians are getting inoculated for
covid19 as we speak
and the prime minister now says hundreds
of thousands of vaccine doses will
arrive in the country before the end of
the year
justin trudeau says the contract for the
modern vaccine has been updated
and up to 168 000 doses will be shipped
before the end of december
health canada hasn't approved that
vaccine yet it's still reviewing the
data but
the chief medical advisor says it looks
promising deliveries
could begin within 48 hours of approval
the moderna vaccine needs to be kept
cold but doesn't need the same special
ultracold freezers as the pfizer
biontech vaccine
that means it will be much easier to
transport and store
including in remote regions as soon as
we get the green
light we'll be ready to go the
territories are scheduled to receive
doses of the modern vaccine
in the coming weeks pending health
canada approval
we're working to ensure the logistics
planning is ready when vaccines are
available
and have already shipped medical grade
freezers to the north
up to 200 000 more doses of the pfizer
biontec vaccine are expected to arrive
next week
it is already approved and today more
doses were rolled out
fantastic in that plane represents hope
for 2021
in st john's the premier of newfoundland
and labrador and the province's top
doctor were on the tarmac to greet the
first shipment
vaccinations are expected to begin there
tomorrow
in alberta doses of the pfizer biome
tech vaccine
also arrive today the first person to
get the vaccine there
was a respiratory therapist in edmonton
bc also administered its first dose
today
to a long-term care worker in vancouver
this rollout is happening sooner than
expected and means thousands of
canadians will be protected from covid19
by early 2021
mike likature has our top story tonight
don't be nervous a little dose of levity
before the first dose of a life-saving
vaccine
personal support worker joanne miner
became ottawa's first
to get the kovit 19 shot in what has
been a slow and steady rollout
of the first vaccinations next week
there could be up to 70 vaccine sites
across canada
as the government confirmed the next
shipment will be 200
000 doses of the pfizer biontech vaccine
this is the good news we all need it
it'll be even better news if health
canada is able to approve the moderna
vaccine this week
most of the 168 000 doses will head to
the territories
which didn't receive the pfizer biontec
vaccine
due to its need for ultra cold storage
approvals for modernist vaccine are
taking a little longer because officials
aren't as familiar with that company's
facilities
similar to the pfizer biontech vaccine
the federal task force is conducting dry
runs this week
to be ready for the moderna vials unlike
last time
the roots are being kept under wraps it
comes from different places
it goes through different places it will
get all canadians
that level of secrecy comes as bc's top
physician expressed concern last week
that the immunization program could be
sabotaged
major general factay says there are a
number of threat indicators they are
monitoring closely
the appropriate level of information is
shared down the line to provinces and
territories
to the law enforcement agencies so that
they take concrete actions
provinces like ontario are preparing for
the moderna vaccine and already have a
plan for the rollout
it'll go into the long-term care homes
first those in greatest need in hot
zones
in lockdown zones those who've had the
kova 19 tragedy visited upon them
health officials say by the first
quarter of next year canada should have
upwards of
6 million doses of vaccines and if all
goes to plan
all canadians who want to be vaccinated
can be
by the end of september 2021
donna okay mike look at her in ottawa
thanks
the first person to get vaccinated in bc
was a frontline health care worker they
and staff who work in long-term care
homes are being given priority because
they are able to get to the vaccination
centers
residents in long-term care will have to
wait unlike in quebec where vaccines are
going to both staff
and residents robin gill explains bc's
vaccine strategy
the delicate delivery a line of defense
against coveted 19 has arrived in
british columbia
4 000 doses are a shot of hope for so
many in this province
but it begins with a caregiver
that's some reassurance for the families
with loved ones in care homes
many of these facilities have been
infested by this pernicious
infection but leslie telford was hoping
residents
like her mom would be included in the
first round of vaccinations
i would definitely feel safer i would
feel that
if residents are given the vaccine they
will have more freedoms and they deserve
it
many seniors in long-term facilities are
confined to their rooms
there's little to no socialization and
visitors aren't allowed for long periods
it's for their protection but it's been
lonely we've been locked down like a
jail robin and it will at least
give us some hope that we can get life
back to normal and give people quality
of life in their homes
caregivers and health care workers are
at the front of the line because they
bring the most
risk to care homes the idea is to create
layers of immunity
we're hoping that this is going to make
a big difference in the short term
on the outbreaks that we're seeing and
the transmissions in care homes and
that's the most
important telford will definitely get
the vaccine and hopes it will come
soon families should maybe also be
considered to receive vaccines
so that there can be some safe
visitation
no one wants to be bringing covet into
a long-term care facility this is a
momentous time but there are still
millions who have to wait for the jab in
the arm to get back to whatever
constitutes normal
in these exceptional times robin gill
global news
vancouver
alberta is also vaccinating frontline
healthcare workers first with priority
being given to those who work in
intensive care
alberta has the most active cases of
covid19 per capita of any canadian
province and patients are flooding into
icus
more beds have been added but hospitals
are struggling to cope
as heather urex west explains staff are
already exhausted
and expect the case count to keep rising
the icu inside edmonton's gray nuns
hospital has become a place
nurse lisa galioni can hardly recognize
the monitors that are everywhere the
computer stations in the hallway
like walking through the hallways like
trying to weave yourself through a maze
without tripping over anything the small
ward is now treating double its usual
patient volume
the icu packed with incredibly sick
covet patients
facing this illness alone they're scared
they're terrified and we're the only
ones there
to hold their hand and that is killing
us
intensive care units in alberta continue
to fill at a chilling speed
since november 1st the numbers have
increased by 385 percent
the numbers of patients with cova that
are hitting the hospital and
particularly
the intensive care units is at a level
that i've never seen before
in 10 years of practice the volume is
absolutely incredible
and it's only going to get worse
alberta's new restrictions took effect
over the weekend
but they've come too late to prevent the
coming surge the number of icu patients
is expected to hit
200 by christmas and will likely keep
rising
well into the new year everybody who
works in healthcare just takes it one
day at a time
because if we look at the math which has
been up there for a month now
you know where we're going alberta
health services has added 90 new icu
beds since the beginning of november
and is working to open additional space
in the coming weeks
but added capacity comes with a cost
non-urgent surgeries and procedures have
had to be postponed while across the
system staff
are being called upon to work longer
hours to cope with the demand still to
come
you're terrified i think underneath
dealing with bats you're you want to do
the best you can for your patients
but there are so many of them
heather urix west global news calgary
in ontario where almost 4 000 people
have now died of covid19
the case count keeps rising too ontario
broke its record for daily new cases
today nearly 2300 new infections were
reported
and 20 more ontarians have died the
province says the spike
may be related to a change in the way
data is being collected but it's unclear
how much of an impact that had
those are still disturbing numbers and
we do know
that in some areas people are still not
complying with the public health rules
and regulations
what's especially concerning is the
surging number of ontario's in hospital
with covid19 there are 921 patients in
the hospital now
249 are in intensive care if the trend
continues ontario could soon surpass the
peak
of the first wave in the spring now to
breaking news out of quebec after weeks
of rising cases there and
hospitalizations
the premier has announced harsh new
measures to try to get the situation
under control
among the new restrictions starting
christmas day all non-essential
businesses will be closed until january
11th
mike armstrong has more details and
reaction
hello it is exactly what peter grant
wanted to avoid the lockdown in the
spring closed his store for 85 days
that one came as a surprise we sort of
figured it was coming
this one didn't grant says premier
francois lego
didn't have a choice i don't blame the
premier no
no it's not his fault that we got a
coronavirus quebec has
averaged over the last week more than
1700 new cases a day
and 26 deaths the fear is if things
continue like this the province's health
care system
already strained could be overwhelmed
quebec's premier says half measures are
no longer enough
the virus has a strong presence
in quebec stronger than expected a month
ago
now quebec already has some of the
tightest rules in the country
but as of december 25th it's getting
even tighter
the quebec government is ordering retail
businesses deemed non-essential
to shut their doors until january 11th
waiting until the 25th
is to leave the holiday rush to
merchants that delay
is welcome news you know we work our way
up to christmas and then finally we can
relax a little bit because the worst is
over
um that's what you'll do this year
exactly yeah
yeah exactly with the kids home and
whatnot
quebec is also extending the holiday
break for schools
they'll open a week later in january
possibly more if the situation in
hospitals doesn't improve
a lot of that depends on what quebecers
do over the holidays
family gatherings outside the household
are banned while the premier announced a
measure he hopes
helps with the stress of the situation
quebec will
allow outdoor activities in groups of up
to eight people
things like hockey or walking as long as
they're not in private homes or yards
it's supposed to be something healthy
that might take a little bit of the
pressure off
during the holidays mike armstrong
global news
montreal millions of canadians have
relied on financial support from the
federal government to get through the
pandemic
now more than 410 000 people are being
asked to confirm
they were eligible for it the canada
revenue agency has sent them letters
asking them about their claims for the
canada emergency response benefit or
serb
the cra calls the letter educational it
explains what qualifies as earned income
to be eligible for the serb
and what does not the cra says not
everyone who receives a letter will be
required to pay the money back
8.9 million canadians have applied for
the benefit more than 81 billion dollars
has been paid out
those who don't meet the criteria are
being asked to repay the money by the
end of the year
to help get ahead of any problems at tax
time next year
a search is underway off the coast of
nova scotia for six missing scallop
fishers
search helicopters and vessels were
dispatched to an area near digby
after the fishing boat issued an
emergency alert shortly before 6
a.m hours later debris was spotted in
the water
and empty life rafts washed up on shore
there's been no sign of the boat itself
the maritime joint rescue coordination
center says waves were two meters high
at the time with winds topping
55 kilometers an hour and off the coast
of california a search is underway for a
sailor who is missing from a canadian
navy ship
canadian master sailor dwayne earl is
believed to have accidentally fallen
overboard hmcs winnipeg
early on monday the u.s coast guard is
helping with the search nearly a
thousand kilometers off the coast of san
francisco
the navy says earl was last seen at 8
a.m and discovered missing at 11 30 a.m
at which point the ship turned back to
look for him
a canadian famous for his clothing
company now in custody coming up the
allegations of sex crimes
involving peter nygard
a canadian who built an international
fashion brand named after himself is in
custody tonight
peter nygard was arrested in his
hometown of winnipeg following a u.s
extradition
request he's been indicted in the
southern district of new york on
multiple charges of sex trafficking
minors and racketeering
two of his own sons have filed lawsuits
against nygard
global's joe scarpelli was in the
courtroom where nygard appeared
joe donna peter nygaard
entered the courtroom in shackles a gray
hoodie and a white
face mask the fashion designer then
slowly made his way over to the
prisoner's box
glanced over at the media quickly before
turning his body towards the front of
the room and resting his head in his
hand
he looked nothing like the man you might
recognize in these pictures
nygaard was arrested monday night in
winnipeg following a request from the
u.s
justice department to begin extradition
proceedings to face
charges in the united states as part of
an ongoing investigation by the fbi
and new york police department the
79-year-old is facing a total of nine
charges the charges include conspiracy
to commit sex
trafficking sex trafficking of a minor
by force
fraud and several more dozens of women
joined a class
action lawsuit accusing nygard of rape
sexual assault and human
trafficking 12 of the victims were
minors when they say the crimes happened
lisa hamba is a florida attorney
representing the women
we've waited so long for this day to
come so long for peter nygar to be
criminally held accountable for his
crimes
and that day is finally here on the one
hand while they're so incredibly
overjoyed that he's being held
accountable
on the other hand it obviously brings up
all the pain and anguish
they've had to live with we spoke to
nygard's lawyer jay prober who says his
client denies
all allegations nygard's next court
appearance is scheduled for january 13th
but his lawyer says he'll be applying
for bail before then
donna joe scarpelli in winnipeg thanks
late today global news spoke with
nygard's eldest son kai
nygaard the 38 year old is not one of
the children who accuses his father of
abuse
feeling like who is this person this
isn't the the per
the father i thought i knew who is this
other person we're hearing about this
monster
it went from investigating asking
questions to
constantly finding out one story after
another
of these horrible behaviors and actions
and it's been incredibly
um intense to
be on the other side of it and
wonder if he was ever going to get
arrested another
high-profile canadian sex abuse trial is
now over
former entertainment mogul gilbert rosen
has been found not guilty of rape and
indecent assault
the founder of the comedy festival just
for laughs was charged in december 2018
he faced accusations dating back to 1980
when he was 25 years old
the complainant who was 20 at the time
testified roseau aggressively tried to
have sex with her
after a night out rosone denied any
assault took place
ahead the tragedy of flight 752 canada
raises red flags about iran's
investigation
it's another sign of the times for
airlines air transat shareholders have
approved the sale of the company to air
canada
shareholders of the montreal-based
company voted during a virtual meeting
the takeover deal is worth 180 million
dollars or five dollars a share
last year air canada had offered 18 a
share to buy air trans ad
the drop in value reflects the impact of
the pandemic
on the travel industry the deal still
needs regulatory approval but
is expected to close early next year
an independent canadian report says iran
should not be investigating the downing
of a ukrainian airlines flight in tehran
nearly a year ago
because it shot down the plane the prime
minister's special adviser on the
disaster ralph goodale issued a 74-page
report
among the findings goodale says there
are concerns about credibility
conflicts of interest and a lack of
transparency and accountability
and that the party responsible for the
situation is investigating
itself largely in secret the report
also says there are indications of
incompetence recklessness and want and
disregard for innocent human life
the flight was shot down by iran's
revolutionary guard shortly after
takeoff from tehran on january 8th
all 176 people on board were killed
including 55 canadians
and 30 permanent residents
calls for change next cleveland's
baseball team finally makes a change
to its name
there is really no excuse anymore for
sports teams to keep using names and
logos that are offensive
times have changed and names that seemed
appropriate years ago
are now considered racist today
cleveland's major league baseball team
got with the program as eric sorenson
reports
the indians the name has been around
more than a hundred years in cleveland
parting with it won't be easy we're
never trying to be disrespectful
no but the team has been under mounting
pressure to recognize it is
disrespectful
it comes two years after the indians
dropped the offensive chief wahoo mascot
in a statement team owner paul dolan
acknowledges the name has detrimental
effects on native american people
the club adding we can unify our
community and bring people together
with a new name philip yenyo confronted
cleveland fans for years
it feels really good that that steps are
being taken
that our voices are being heard it's
taken decades for many u.s colleges to
abandon
indian-based nicknames and offensive
mascots in canada
mcgill university only dropped the term
redmond from men's varsity teams a year
ago they're now the redbirds
but pro sports teams have been
especially slow with enormous
investments in their iconic symbols
this past summer however protests
against systemic racism brought new
demands to drop such imagery once and
for all
the washington redskins finally gave in
after sponsors threatened to walk out
they're managing this season without a
nickname the edmonton eskimos are also
looking for a new team name
and now so is cleveland's baseball team
except
not for another year to give them time
to switch to a new name
and perhaps move some merchandise while
they can some say it's a mistake to
delay
once you say you're not going to use it
anymore you can't use it anymore
or else you're sort of defeating the
purpose of changing it still the name
will go
and that's the important thing says one
baseball writer it's not a popular
decision
in cleveland but it had to be it had to
be made several other sports teams still
have controversial names and the
question is
who might be next to change eric
sorenson global news
toronto and that is global national for
this tuesday i'm donna friesen
tonight's your canada is this picture
postcard shot of emerald lake lodge in
field
bc look at that there are beautiful
spots all over canada please email us
yours to viewers at globalnational.com
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow take care of yourselves
bye-bye
[Applause]
[Music]